bueno como es sabido usted ha tenido la
oportunidad de entrevistar y de haber
estado junto a vicente fernández
cuéntenos cómo fueron esos encuentros y
qué recuerdos tiene usted del rey de la
ranchera
saludos desde colombia a santiago
efectivamente vicente fernández la
primera vez que salió de mexico lo hizo
a colombia
atendiendo una invitación de nuestro
programa de televisión el show de las
estrellas allí en la televisión en esa
época de blanco y negro vicente
interpretó las canciones tradicionales
de su repertorio que luego se
constituyeron en éxitos en toda colombia
realmente vicente fernández ha sido un
referente para todos los artistas
colombianos que gustan de esta música
popular de la música ranchera todos
quieren cantar como vicente fernández
todos tratan de invitarlo y sus
canciones las cantan todo el mundo
porque definitivamente colombia
un país ranchero donde gusta muchísimo
este género musical y todos estamos muy
tristes por la partida de vicente
fernández en los restaurantes en todas
partes se hacen homenajes a vicente
fernández se escucha su música se pasan
sus vídeos en la televisión colombiana
han realizado varios especiales como
homenaje a este gran ídolo de la canción
latinoamericana ahora jorge vicente
habla bastante sobre su propia muerte a
veces en sus conciertos y lo hizo con
usted durante una entrevista hace
muchísimos años algo que he visto hoy a
la distancia moviliza muchísimo recuerda
esos momentos claro que si él hablaba de
la vida naturalmente claro y hablaba de
sus fans de su público que amaba
definitivamente y naturalmente pues
también hablaba que algún día tenía que
irse de este mundo pero que donde él
estuviera seguiría cantando eran sus
palabras eran sus frases cada vez que
hablaba de este tema pero
definitivamente vicente fernández
seguirá vivo en el recuerdo de todo este
público de colombia esta gente de
nuestro país que lo amaba que lo quería
y que seguía su música sus canciones
ahora un poco ya adelantó en la primera
pregunta pero se lo quiero preguntar más
concretamente que representa para usted
vicente fernández no sólo para méxico
también para américa latina y también no
sólo a nivel artístico
bueno vicente fernández pues
definitivamente ha sido una persona que
ha unido a nuestros pueblos porque a
través de la música se puede lograr
vicente con sus conciertos también
llevaba paz alegría a todos los rincones
de la patria y también de su país de
méxico porque era un gran referente para
todo este pueblo
latinoamericano este pueblo de méxico
que también llora su partida en esta
oportunidad aquí en colombia todos
estamos muy tristes las estaciones de
radio realizan programas especiales
siempre se escucha la música de vicente
fernández